Hey.
Welcome.
We're really excited that you chose to learn Java.
Yeah, Java is one of the most popular programming languages out there.
Yup. And together we're going to learn how to use it to
program a computer to do whatever you want it to do.
That's true.
In this lesson you will program the computer to
remember numbers and texts using variables.
You'll get to use those variables to do calculations that even us humans can't do.
In lesson two you'll get to teach
the computer how to make decisions when faced with multiple choices.
And in lesson three you'll get to write your own sets of
instructions for computers to follow using functions.
Yup. And in lesson four you will get to write programs that can repeat
instructions over and over again for billions of times if needed.
By lesson five you should be ready to work on your first big project.
You'll need to install some tools to get you started,
but don't worry, we'll walk you through that step by step when we get to them.
All right. Let's get started.